it's scary for us you know we don't know
if there's truly code with 19 in there
yet so we have to act like there is on
almost every case we go into right now
in the wake of the pandemic companies
that cleaned everything from crime
scenes to chemical spills to radioactive
waste are being called in to disinfect
hot spot areas from the coronavirus
these workers go to businesses and homes
where confirmed cases of koban 19 have
been documented in some cases leading to
death putting themselves at risk of
being infected with the virus they are
an often unseen group of central workers
on the frontlines of the outbreak to see
what it takes to be on the frontlines
we followed Cory Chalmers the CEO of
Siri clean a company that specializes in
biohazard and crime-scene cleanup for a
day he showed us what it looks like to
be a professional cleaner during the
outbreak she unfortunately laid on the
ground for at least a few days which
results in early safety composition
which can result in bacteria help him
clean up sanitizing services like scary
clean a scrubbing down places suspected
of being contaminated by the novel
coronavirus
that includes cruise ships offices
warehouses factories coffee shops in the
homes of the deceased like this one
woman who may have had kovin 19 before
entering a potentially contaminated
space Chalmers and his team suit up
wearing personal protective equipment
similar to health care workers on the
front lines while the CDC hasn't
confirmed any cases of someone getting
infected from the novel coronavirus
living on a surface it still recommends
disinfecting surfaces regularly and
researchers have found that the virus
can live on
certain surfaces for hours and even days
we were there also / Jesus we wear n95
masks respirators so we're fully
encapsulated we can't breathe in any of
the particulates that are out there
floating around we we're shooting
everywhere develop loves we're taped at
the scene so we're really not allowing
anything to get inside of that suit or
under our masts because we got to take
this off and go home of the day so we
don't want to bring anything home with
us with this respirator mask on Chalmers
enters the contaminated space and first
begins to remove any soiled clothes or
materials from all surfaces after
disposing in the biohazard waste
Chalmers Team scrubs contaminated
surfaces with an alcohol or bleach-based
product this step removes biofilms with
our the work that Sterry clean does has
to be thorough so to confirm surfaces
are properly cleaned
Chalmers uses ATP monitors to test for
cellular activity since as of now
there's no test that detects the köppen
19 virus on surfaces so we measure
services it's soared energy every cell
so we know once the surface has passed
ATP monitors test
Chalmers can move on to the next step
disinfection which will penetrate any
present viruses not only Cova 19 and we
do not have to see but we want to make
it safe for them to go in there Chalmers
team follows a strict CDC approved
process for applying hospital-grade EPA
registered disinfectant that claimed to
kill emerging pathogens
Chalmers sprays disinfectant on all
surfaces and touch points
letting it sit for the proper dwell time
before wiping the surface
that includes door handles light
switches keyboards the backs and arms of
chairs plus all horizontal surfaces like
tables countertops and desks if it dries
before the mandatory dwell time then the
disinfectant is ineffective and they do
this with electrostatic guns mechanical
spraying systems and handheld foggers
whole room misting systems are used in
larger spaces to fill rooms with
invisible disinfection mist in smaller
cases like this one Chalmers team uses
electrostatic guns to put an electric
charge on the mist so it wraps on the
back side of services and coats them
evenly throughout not something we like
to do every day but this is what we do
to make a situation better for the
family so they don't have to do it make
sure we're doing our best since their
first kovat nineteen related call in
early March the company has worked on
dozens of cases over that every call
coming in I don't think code 19 is going
away so I really think it's gonna change
our industry because we see ongoing for
years